welcome to this video I'm playing Molly
gasps would my old nemesis yeah
can I do something crazy against him
let's do something crazy I really hate
the games against the guy so why not do
something crazy I'm playing the black
majima gambit
he's declining yeah so how can I can I
get some some sort of a check I really
want a sharp position him playing young
castling yeah Knight takes Bishop F to
Bishop g5 is a very embarrassing thing
which should be avoided but that's not a
bad position at all if I have to react
to that try to be quick because he will
as you know if you have watched some of
my videos he will play each and every
position on time and yeah you know okay
this is just good for white come on I'm
just going to to blast this guy out of
the water here I'm totally fed up with
him that seemed takes bishop takes and
winning and I'm threatening to capture
anyway
my scores honey I have seven draws
against him nine losses and no wind with
the chess explained account which is
really crazy he's not even a better
player I mean in the tournament chess or
whatever check let's see me tonight - if
fire fire that should be should be
really good the only problem is of
course that I don't have this bishop is
not playing how do I get this into play
do I need to get it into play is there
something else I mean he's really really
in trouble here I can do h4 h5 but
without the bishop mmm not easy
yeah that's not not that easy really
because of my dad bishop
the good thing is that besides them I
mean I have a huge a huge firm
positional advantage but I also have an
extra pawn which is really useful
okay so I have to trade this really no
no choice
yeah not him he's taking to indirectly
okay I want to keep the porn but I also
have still have some some vague chances
to play against this king g4 h4 and
stuff
check okay yeah at least the safe yeah
anyway
okay he's six he's six and rook d7 I
don't know let's I can yes rook F to
regret too is kind of annoying
tweenage who I wanted to play six but he
can really just take that
you really can take that
hmm yeah that probably wasn't a great
idea em just this whole thing he's 6
root chicks chick I don't have I don't
have a window surprisingly
it's really really strange on that part
- how to understand everything here rook
F - I can take on b5 which is a resource
that I had overlooked before
rook age six King edge these Rock t6
check kimchi five
check let's do that
the six check King g5 I have at least
queen g6 rook g6 and queen h1
I think it should win I'm not totally
totally sure
look t6 King defies Quincey I know I
grew up to six King h5 it's that's no
win right I mean I can always give this
check on g6 and play rock before but I'm
not sure if I'm winning it looks very
nice but still not sure if I win okay
time when he didn't take it so I can
give this check now on age 7 yeah I
definitely exactly that but now what now
this check King is 7 there is no mate
which is kind of curious at least I
don't see it and I don't see a checkmate
probably I'm totally blind
I don't see a major we have kink and
threatening to check on h8 and Luke t7
I don't know Ruka 5 is also threatened
Jack come on this is a window right
black resigned this is very satisfying
so this is what I need to do against him
play some offbeat nonsense and take the
king yeah sort of thought of that that
before but I don't know he very often
gets this kind of idiotic and games and
win his own time but okay I need to do
some direct attack it seems yeah I don't
know around here it looks like white
should win easily but I'm really playing
without without them and some scroll a
little bit back here I'm playing I'm
playing without earn without the bishop
and this is this is really check really
a bit of a problem
fifty-five Andrew P one it's the
computer suggestion yeah maybe the
computer finds a way without the benefit
as a human player I wanted to get all
pieces involved I'm definitely keeping
an advantage here but I'm not playing it
right definitely not Jackie this here
yeah and here I should probably just
take the pawn on e5 around here I'm
drifting here yeah and now check this
move which which I spotted and for
unfortunately what I was saying is I saw
this variation and rook t4 and it is
winning yes okay I wasn't completely
sure if I'm winning or I mean I saw I
get the Queen back and I mean his King
is on h4 and it looks really problematic
but I wasn't sure if I'm winning but the
computer says it's plus two so I am
winning so this this this rook takes age
six was the champ decider
mmm very nice rookie six winning oh I
miss dad that's nice
look at this check beautiful checkmate
kind of an epaulette meter with the
twist funny yeah okay this was winning
what what about my move was this winning
as well yeah it was and now he six check
winning the Queen so yeah this is the
recipe for success against the sky play
the black majima try to meet him okay
well thanks for watching